we have to make goals and we have to
make them and you have to decide and
start acting on them before January 1st
doing goals on January 1st is weak
that's nonsense
[Music]
what's up we got a great episode we're
doing
um a crazy AI tool but my favorite new
AI thing kind of mind-blowing Sam you
gotta admit that was pretty mind-blowing
correct it was awesome uh I just signed
up for the waiting list and I hope
they'll actually let me on but it's
amazing so this is this one's this one's
mind bending uh we also talked about
arbitrages so kind of like money making
Arbitrage schemes that either us or our
friends have done uh that was a little
fun one uh what else did we do we talked
about setting goals so what the New
Year's gonna happen in like four weeks
so we think you should start your goals
immediately and we talked about our
categories for goals and then we also
talked about Twitter so there's a bunch
of drama going on Twitter with pipe
happening this company that's
potentially gonna go bankrupt and a few
other things happening in our lives
about getting fights on Twitter and
whether we should react or not it's kind
of gossipy but I love that so that's the
episode check it out
all right what up we're back enough of
this holiday enough of this holiday
nonsense I was uh I was Thanksgiving
it was easy Ethan came over you know you
know our friend Ethan uh I don't know if
you know Ethan but he came over and he
killed a turkey and he brought it over
pretty great
did you bring like a carcass in no he
like
I don't know how they kill it actually I
think they just chopped their head off
and then he plucked it and brought it
over and we ate a turkey it was awesome
have you ever done that uh no I mean
come on
what are we talking about here I don't
know I know you have you have idiot
Roots I would have thought that like
your parents your parents have probably
killed the chicken or two if we want to
do Turkey this year
um
we all had like a moment we looked at
each other like yo turkey sucks right
and then we just decided to go with
chicken but uh nevertheless
we're back uh you have some stuff on
this list that I want to know about so I
want to start with yours all I see is
just a call to action it says need to
start working on New Year's plans now in
all caps get these implemented so dude
you're like my thing you I think that
starting a New Year's thing on January
1st is kind of the most small boy thing
you can possibly do it's like could you
be more basic just if you have an idea
start it now why are you waiting yeah
yeah like at at the worst you have to
start at December 15th and I'm a big fan
of goals I write goals I write my goals
out I tell them my wife what they are
and so like we're on the same page I
tell other people what they are you
gotta have goals and I break them out
into six categories how does the wife
react you just say my goal is eight
percent body fat she's like all right
okay dude the fit itself women don't
give a we've talked about this
ripped the only people who care about
being ripped are other dudes so like
I've given up trying to do other ripped
guys yeah I've given up trying to like
make my wife like me physically like any
more than she already does that will
never happen so you know the fitness
thing is for me and impressing other men
so that's all there is to that but I
have so the first three categories of
the three F's family financial Fitness
and then mind adventure and other so let
me give you some examples so uh
Financial that's easy so how much money
you want to make you want to make money
from different projects things like that
family for us it's like you know like
for me like I like going to couples
therapy do you do couples therapy no
never dude you should it's awesome it's
just like it's just like Fitness doesn't
matter if you're ripped or not ripped
like you exercise you got to do it you
know my wife is old school she thinks
like you know she's like yeah therapy's
great other people should do it but my
suggestion it's like oh you're saying
we're broken yeah she's like everybody's
great for freaks you know like it's
really so supportive of other people
doing it but if you dare mention that I
will take it as a personal assault yeah
you should do it it's awesome it's a fun
way it's also uh it's just good I I
think people should do it Fitness is
easy that one's easy but then mind so
for mine it's like how if you want to
read books throughout the year
um for me I wanted to have more fun this
year because I was pretty uptight
leading up to it uh up to this year and
then the fifth category is the really
fun one which most people don't have
which is Adventures so for me I wanted
to do like a car class like a driving
car class I wanted to go hunting uh I
technically I didn't do that but I did
go fishing uh I wanted to
um Camp a couple times
fishing hunting does it is that the same
thing I went to Whole Foods
they're not the same thing I wanted to
look something in the eye kill it and
then put it in my mouth that's that was
the goal I wanted to kill something and
then consume it and I was unable to do
it with an animal that wasn't you know
that was on land
um so anyway these are my six categories
are you gonna do that this year are you
gonna create some categories
do it I do it a little differently but I
have a very similar it's the same idea
it's just a little slightly different
frame but I do basically I score myself
health wealth
um so what is it health wealth fun or
like play is kind of that one and then
love and then the last one is
um it's like self-respect like how do I
view myself and so those are my five
categories and I basically say on a
scale of one to five
where how would I score myself currently
the present moment and then what would
it take to be to feel like it's a five
what would make me feel like it's a five
and I start to sort of dream that up
okay yeah if this this and this and then
what I do is every three months I just
go look at that scoreboard and I say
have I made progress on those like have
any meters moved up or down
my check engine lights I gotta see if
there's an issue I gotta address it if
there's if I make a positive progress
all right fantastic
what was your self-respect number this
year
self-respect was pretty high was a four
and um four out of five so pretty good
yeah that one used to be lower so like I
added it because I was like you know all
these things are pretty good something
feels off what's missing and I go
I think I would respect me more if I was
doing some things a little differently
so I added that I go you know I don't
really care
you know that's the one I care the most
about basically you know my my
self-esteem my my judgment on myself and
um and it's the truest gauge because
like even if all the surface level stuff
looks fine
it's like only I have full evidence of
of the little that I am and
only I see all those moments where I
take the shortcuts or where I lack the
discipline or where I choose the small
boy path instead of doing something more
adventurous so only I know
and so that's why I decided all right I
gotta I gotta add that to the scoreboard
this is the most broy thing ever but on
Joe Rogan's podcast uh guy Richie you
know guy Richie he directed like snatch
and of these other movies yeah he uh he
goes I live life as if I'm the director
of my own movie and he said that line
and it was awesome that's a really cool
line and so that's why I created an
adventure category because I'm like dude
I'm such a I just sit behind my
computer all day like I don't do
anything like sick like I'm watching
this James Bond movie and he's like
blowing up in an Aston Martin I'm
like this is way so much cooler than
having like a Shopify store like I I
need to I need to do more adventurous
stuff and so I think it's good that we
both have Adventure or fun you got to
call yours the uh the four F so family
financial fitness and fun that'd be way
easier to remember and then self-respect
yeah system
[Laughter]
I actually was uh I don't know if people
would be interested in doing this it's
not really like it's not really like
worth my time but I kind of want to do
it anyways which is like I want to do a
it's not a course it's like a
what do you call it when it's like um
like Michael Jordan used to do this
where in the mornings he would go work
out at 5am or 6 a.m and he called it The
Breakfast Club and he was basically just
like like he started doing it alone and
then some guy saw him like walking
through the hotel that you know some guy
came back from partying and saw Michael
Jordan go into the to the gym he's like
what are you doing Mike he's like oh
yeah I work out every day at 5am you
should come be here tomorrow and then
the guy came and then slowly but surely
the whole team ended up going to The
Breakfast Club and they had a great year
they won the championship that year and
I kind of want to do that for kick
starting the new year which is like
first of all We're not gonna do it
January 1st but I just want a batch of
people who all want to like level up in
their you know their four F's basically
dude I've thought about this so just be
like yo it's a group and we're just
gonna be here we're gonna be together
for like
10 days or 21 days or something like
that it's like we're just going to get
Hella momentum off feeding off of each
other's like progress and energy and
it's just literally going to be a like
uh you know you put in I don't know like
100 bucks and you join this group chat
and then I will every morning I will
drop kind of like um
something that's high energy to spark
the group and then you just check in
with your and it's just a momentum
Club it's just for people who want to
build massive amount of momentum
um so I kind of want to do this I
actually really just want to be a member
of one but I don't think this exists so
therefore I think I might create it and
I might kick it off like you know
whatever December
15th or December like 20th or something
Have you heard of 75 hard
of course yeah that's yeah that's the
inspiration for this this guy's crazy so
his name's I don't know his last name
Andy f i Andy frisella so he basically
has like a a supplement company and if
you look at the podcast charts this week
you and I were like number 12 or 13.
this guy's always like number two or
number one so he's got like a pretty big
following and he's he's I think it's a
daily podcast so he does a pretty good
job there but he started this thing
called 75 hard and here's the rules if
you skip a day you have to start over if
you miss a task you have to start over
at day one you have to pick a diet and
follow it and no alcohol and no cheat
meals you have to drink a water a gallon
of water a day complete two daily
workouts one of which uh two daily
workouts that are 45 minutes each one of
each one of which has to be outside read
10 pages a day of a non-fiction book and
take a progress photo every day and you
have to do that for 75 days uh and he's
killed it if you look at the app
downloads it's like 10 bucks for five
dollars or something for the app there's
thousands and thousands of reviews he's
totally turned this into a movement he's
done a really good job at that yeah yeah
that's I think that's like the a plus
version of what I'm talking about mine
is way simpler because I'm not trying to
work out twice a day and like you know
carry a gallon of water around or
whatever it's more like
what is one simple thing I can do just
to create momentum because I think most
people
most people assume the answer is so hard
that they literally just do nothing
right it's like if you're not working
out you don't need a workout plan you
need to walk to the gym and like be in
the gym for five minutes ten minutes so
do all push-up like like just a full a
Sensei forward progress and uh and and
more than anything usually it's like
especially with the New Year stuff it's
like figure out what even what even do
you really want like do do you have
enough Clarity in what you really want
where it's like on the tip of your
tongue and therefore your brain is
recognizing opportunities to achieve
that thing
all day right if it's not on the tip of
your tongue then your brain's not going
to be seeing it and you know seeing
those moments or those opportunities for
it to happen I'll give you an example of
one of these like my trainer so I move
my workouts to the morning so now it's
great I start my start my day wake up
literally go down to the garage
um 8 am so at 8am is the start of the
workout so
I do that right before I do this and he
always gives me these little stories but
I turn them into games so he'll be like
dude on the way over here he's like he's
like I asked myself you know he's like I
was he's like I stopped at Whole Foods
or whatever and this like old lady like
clipped my achilles with her cart and my
initial reaction was to be like what the
you know like he was yeah it's like if
you get you know flat you know flat
tired in the back with this car it's
like dude you know watch what you're
doing you look he's like look back it's
a grandma I had to laugh at myself for
how mad I was gonna get for nothing and
he's like so I decided I was like all
right before I leave Whole Foods I gotta
reverse the karma I'm gonna light
someone up today he's like I'm gonna
make somebody's day right now like
somebody is gonna have a laugh because
of me because of how you know I was in
this mood I'm gonna switch it and um and
so then he tells me the story of how he
did it and I'm like that's a great
little daily chat like one daily
challenge for me today I'm gonna light
somebody up today and I'm gonna make
their day I'm gonna make them laugh I'm
gonna do something unexpected that just
makes somebody really really happy and
then I took that as my Challenge and
like by by noon I had done it and I was
like that's just a little thing that
wasn't gonna happen but it was a lot of
forward momentum towards something that
I personally care about which is being
that type of dude being that type of
dude who's in that type of mood who is
contagious with other people when I hear
Light someone up I don't think make
their day good I think the opposite well
yeah there is like a
we're not playing Halo here or whatever
light them up like you know brighten
their day
I feel that well I think that's good let
me know what your what you're how you're
gonna organize this well now that I said
it I feel like I have to do it this was
an idea that I was not gonna do until uh
I just got rope-a-doped into doing it
here on the Pod but okay we'll do it
um okay do you have anything else on
this new year thing that you want to
talk about no I just think that we have
to make goals and we have to make them
and you have to decide and start acting
on them before January 1st doing goals
on January 1st is weak that's nonsense
that's nonsense we can't be doing that
you know we did a a Spartan Race I think
together but that one and Tough Mudder
they do this thing where before you get
to the start line like it's like oh I'm
here to do the Tough Mudder race you go
you're trying to get to the starting
point and there's like a wall you got to
climb just to get to the starting line
and um you know it's sort of like
laughable it's like stereotypical thing
but it's like yeah but it's fun but it's
fun and it's it's a it's a Line in the
Sand it's like either you believe that
this sort of thing is awesome or you
should just leave now honestly if you're
like and I can about the wall
before the starting line well guess what
happens after the starting line a bunch
of walls and a bunch of obstacles and
adversity that's coming your way and if
you aren't willing to do it before you
know to go before go like you know
you're not this is not for you and I
just love that like I remember filing
that away in the in the mental swipe
file of like
that's how you build a brand is you like
you think about what would be the way
that we would do a starting line do
before you even get to the start line
there's an obstacle and um I remember
thinking that so that's kind of like the
New Year's thing to me there's like the
the starting line is not January 1st
it's now
yeah whenever I create like you know
everyone has this thing where they go
I'm gonna eat healthy starting tomorrow
and that just says to them like all
right I can pick up now but I'm gonna
start tomorrow and whenever I think of
dieting I'm like no whenever you have
the idea to like I'm gonna do this you
have to actually start the second you
can't do that same thing and but I'll be
like I was like if I have the plate in
front of me I'm like all right I'm
already feeling guilty
it's not finish this meal and start
healthy tomorrow it's I have to
physically go take this plate to the
garbage can and throw it away but first
and I take the last bite like I'm a
prisoner on death row and this is the
last bite and I just Savor that last
bite like it is like every particle of
that bite is like my heaven and then
after that bite I can throw the thing
away that's right you got to start right
away so that's my whole thing with goals
if you're gonna do them you got to start
right away what uh what's this are what
do you want to go what's the most
interesting thing Arbitrage that and
money quote automatically have me
interested okay let me do the money
quote real quick uh saw this and this is
something that I would say like
resonated with me as a lesson for the
year right
um we all know your boys lost a lot of
money this year we know we know what
happened we know that the that there
there is such a thing as the risk
playing out this year and one thing that
really stood out was when I read this
quote I read it on Twitter and I'll read
it to you by the way how do you feel
about losing money are you actually
upset
uh look nobody nobody likes losing money
I don't like losing the money but the
adversity is my opportunity so but do
you go to do go to bed do
um do you go to bed worried
no
what's that gonna do well most people
that way I'd be like what's that gonna
do for me and then I would stop okay so
you're you are worried but you're not
that worried you're sleeping fine so
don't worry it worry wouldn't even
worry's not even close it's more like
the if there is an emotion that I would
feel that's negative it would be like ah
or ah right like it's like
well is it out of fear or out of it out
of like kicking myself like dang I made
a mistake or
um so maybe I should have thought like
you're like ashamed of yourself like
you're like you're just upset that I
made a bad decision yeah it's like oh I
you know it's like if I'm playing ping
pong and I hit the ball into the net
it's like ah that was an unfortunate
there was an unforced error could I have
done something differently could I have
shifted my angle slightly could I have
taken a little less power on it or
whatever right like there are things you
ask yourself could I not have read the
signs differently or hedged or done
certain things in order to protect
myself but but do you feel pressured now
that you got to go make that up are you
like I put all this work in to get
the initial thing now I gotta go and put
more time in to go get it back no no
because I see this is the good thing
about playing being a poker degenerate
for so long is like I've already gone
through that like mental like trap a
thousand times so I know how to I know
how to get out of those handcuffs like
if you play poker you you will on a
weekly basis have this feeling of like
oh God I'm on a downswing either because
I'm playing bad or bad luck or whatever
and then the urge is to get it back and
I've literally been the dude who walks
to the ATM at the casino and it's like
would you like to pay the 17 service fee
I'm like if I could give it to me and
then I like push it I get the get the
600 out and I hit the Max and then I'm
like all right I got 600 I'm three grand
in the hole and I gotta get it back and
then I lose the 600 I'm like well later
that night as I'm reflecting in my
comped hotel room because I lost so much
money which is the ultimate backhanded
compliment where they give you a free
free room they're like please sir come
back tomorrow we would love to take your
money again
um they're like don't go home you know
they're like as I'm sitting there laying
there and I think to myself you know
what I shouldn't have gone and got that
extra money I should have cooled off I
should have gone with a clear mind I
should have uh you know gambled at the
right Stakes so that I wasn't trying to
win it all back in the next hand or the
next hour or whatever it is so playing
poker online and offline you know I've
done a lot of the rookie mistakes
hundreds of times and at some point you
realize okay gotta manage my bankroll
properly so I can't go broke secondly if
you lose you live to fight another day
go clear your head change your state
don't come back and gamble right away uh
second like the money you're playing
with now is not to win back the money
you just won or lost uh so if you want a
bunch of money that doesn't mean play it
Reckless now if you lost much money that
doesn't play play desperate now like
you'd have to play in isolation you have
to play the odds and you have to play
you know the best game you can to try to
make positive decisions so you learn
that in poker now for me with business
or investing that's all like baked into
my DNA because I spent like 10 years
doing in that sure all right well and so
what about the money quote all right the
money quote is this
he goes by the way this was I just saw
this on Twitter I don't know who I don't
know the source of this it's from a book
so it says for one thing we usually act
too quickly when we're trying to make
money and too slowly when we're trying
to protect our money if you're pressed
to make a decision ask yourself am I
doing this to protect my money or to
make my money more make more money if
the answer is protect you should act
more quickly if the answer is to make
money you should act slowly and I don't
know about I don't know if this is true
for you I think you're wired quite
differently than me but for me this was
like
um you know like when you're in a room
and you say something and you found that
Echo spot and it just bounces on all the
walls and you hear it a thousand times
because what do you do it's exactly like
when I feel like there's a moment to
make money I act very impulsively
quickly I kind of I'll not put as much
thought in research or diligence or
patience into making addition I won't
sleep on it because if it's making money
I try to strike while they're in time
and that served me mailed well in some
ways but it's also been the source of
many mistakes
and then there's the other side of it
when I'm trying to like protect money so
for example I'll tell you in the crypto
case right now it's like I I saw her
because we were doing the milk road we
started reporting about these like
collapses before they happen like the
lunar collapsed right before it happened
the Celsius one before it happened we
put it in the newsletter the um
uh the the FTX one and in each case I
kind of was like oh let me see how this
plays out when The Prudent thing to do
would have been act more swiftly and say
hey just out of an abundance of caution
let me withdraw my money out of this
thing or let me place a hedge let me let
me do something to protect myself here
and I kind of was just like let me sit
back and let's see when the action
arrives then I'll take then I'll put my
my dukes up right and in reality so I've
learned that for me this is a really
good rule of thumb which is if I'm
trying to make money that's the time to
slow down be a little more diligent if
I'm trying if it's about if I should if
I'm in a protect money mode I should be
pushing the action and acting more
decisively and quickly because my nature
is to do the opposite dude my nature is
to do so I'm pretty slow when it comes
to money making stuff I'm like no I'm
gonna like actually assess him if I want
to do this if if it involves like a
business that I have to operate or think
about I go you know do I want to do this
for a long period of time let me
actually reflect on this but then when
it comes to selling and protecting I
don't I don't so like if I buy a piece
of prop property or something like that
and let's say it's not working I'm like
I don't care I'm holding on to this if I
if I own like some type of uh public
Equity I go I just pretend that it like
I just can't sell I've never sold a a
stock in my life and I'm not sure if
that's actually wise you've never sold a
stock
um never I don't think so I don't think
ever
not one ever meh maybe when I was
around I was like trying to
create content for the podcast when the
uh when the AMC thing happened and I
think I bought 500 worth of stuff and
then I sold it when I earned like
a 10 return in one day and I was just
like around to like figure out
how Robin Hood but that was more
experimental but no besides that I don't
think I've ever really sold this stock
in my life I think that maybe my um
wealth manager or like my banker like
does like tax harvests uh like he's like
yeah but like me personally I have never
sold I've never sold a single stock
that's amazing uh wow okay so great
you're wired very well for for Success
when it comes to you sold wait but so
when you you like buy and sell like
equities yeah for sure no I don't ever
do that I've never done that in my life
I don't think that's the right thing to
do do you actually think that you're
gonna outperform someone who actually
does this for a living and has like 20
billion dollars or 50 billion dollars in
assets well either way you're thinking
that right like even if you don't sell
you're putting your money in assuming
you're I don't think I'm not trying to
outperform somebody else I'm simply
trying to make more money I'm trying to
increase my rate of return I'm trying to
make more money or reduce my losses and
so one strategy is buy and hold forever
buy good assets and hold them forever
and another ass another one is uh Sean
wakes up feels a certain type of way and
starts making decisions that he
shouldn't be making right like what if I
told you that you're allowed to go start
a private business and you're allowed to
go do things like that but any profit
that you make what it has to go into
this pile of money that you can never
touch again unless you want to withdraw
the king games but you cannot invest in
anything other than this one thing but
it will get a 7.5 percent return every
single year for the next hundred years
would you accept that 7.5 return
shoot me in the head why don't you I
mean come on what if I said you can only
have white bread and turkey slices for
the rest of your wow so you wouldn't
take that 7.5 return every single year
no
dude that is the craziest thing on Earth
really
than that I'm not saying I'm a day
trader but I guess what I guess what I'm
saying wait so you I would not want to
literally not be able to touch my money
forever nor would I would not want to no
I mean not be able to make any decisions
it's like Ah that's okay if I if I if I
if I over perform for underperformance
not even for that it's just like what's
the fun in living like that that doesn't
sound fun to me what but in this
scenario you can go and start you can go
and generate wealth but any like wealth
that you make that you don't spend on
things that you actually consume and use
for so I can't invest in startups I love
investing in startups you can't invest
in startups it just all your money just
goes you're basically you you you could
spend your money how you want in terms
of like buying homes or whatever
anything that you want to have a cool
life but all your investment goes into a
thing where you don't ever touch it and
it just makes seven and a half percent a
year that is dude do you realize seven
and a half percent is that's basically
if over a hundred years that's what the
markets do it doesn't happen every year
you know some years it's 30 sometimes
it's negative 20. but I would totally
take that any day of the week no
decisions have to be made you don't have
to worry seven and a half percent
doubles every 10 years I put a portion
of my money in that right so I have a
portion of my money in index funds that
I don't touch I don't think about but
all one of it wasn't fun
that's my best offer and I'm not giving
you a dollar more than 17 you have to
admit so for all of our listeners here I
actually think that most people might
think like you at this right now but can
you and if you're listening you have to
ask yourself this but Sean can you
acknowledge that the seven and a half
intervention what's that listen listen
can you acknowledge that the seven and a
half percent is financially the safe and
correct move like that will in turn I
don't know how like you know nerd
Bankers do the math but like
statistically speaking like that is the
best that is the best probability to get
like a high a good rate of return no I
disagree uh here's why that is crazy
here's why here's why here's why
um I can take that money and just invest
it in my own businesses I can put the
capital up for my own business and grow
them at a much faster rate I've done
that multiple times I did that well in
this scenario you could can still do
that I'm just saying like any profit I
can't take I don't take money put in my
own businesses you're saying yeah I'm
saying you can start businesses but like
any you'll you basically have two you
have one account or you have two
accounts a checking account that's just
like for your living and then just like
an investment count and then you could
go and like hey look I'm gonna go and
start put a little bit of money into my
own privately Health company camps and
you can do private Health companies but
you can't invest in anything outside of
those things
uh yeah so I think that for most people
that is the correct answer I think that
for me that is not the correct answer
for two minutes and most people think
they are not most people which is crazy
here that's true that's true for an
above average person like me and
everybody says something's like I'm
above average too
the average person thinks they're above
average this is absolutely crazy to me
because if you just look at like all the
evidence here like even no more
and I put it into either Investments
that I have access to like I think my
startup portfolio is going to beat seven
and a half percent average I
fundamentally believe that so I'm going
to put some amount of capital in that
like if you're betting that your starter
portfolio or my startup my angel
portfolio is going to be worse than
seven and a half percent
that's you could say that and it might
end up being true I'm not saying it's
not true I personally don't believe
that's going to be true it has other
problems it's in liquid and there's
other things like that but I think the
rate of returns will be closer to 20 or
30 percent and so I'm going to put some
of my money towards that I'll put some
into my own businesses I might buy a
business or buy a minority stake in
other people's businesses that are
growing 20 30 40 a year and again a
different liquid different liquidity
different risk profiles but like I do
think that that is how I would prefer to
play the game and I'm okay with the fact
that this might mean that I don't beat
the seven and a half percent I've you
know I'd rather be the hair than the
tortoise and I'm okay if the tortoise
wins The Tortoise wins but the hair had
a lot more fun and I just sort of
believe that you know I'm gonna do well
financially through my own businesses
and my investments that like I'd rather
do it the way that's a little more
engaging to the brain then do you have
any money and index funds Bogle head or
whatever you call yourselves that yeah
do you have any money in index funds
yeah yeah I do I've hundreds of
thousands of dollars in index funds I I
I think you're crazy dude the way that I
look at it is my privately held
companies those generate wealth those
generate uh you know cash flow and
income and then I only want to focus on
maximizing returns in that area and then
the whole rest I just put in this thing
that I don't even log into I think
that's a good strategy I'm not saying
that's a bad strategy I think that is a
good strategy it is just not the one I
picked uh that I that I choose for
myself I act I think for most for you
you are not most people not actually in
the sense that your Investments are good
I do agree that they will be great but
you are different from the sense in the
sense of you don't get stressed out
about things but for most every other
person out there I think they should 100
follow my the way that I do things most
people don't have a floating light bulb
on their desk do they but I do and if
you got this floating light bulb on your
desk that you bought because you wanted
it to hover in the air you're probably
not the type of guy who's who's you know
fist pumping about the seven and a half
percent index fund that they're never
gonna look at it for 50 years
alright then
um yeah most four most dangerous words
in the English language
401K
the stupidest you've ever said
I'm going full Skip Bayless on you
um uh all right what do you got all
right so that's the money quote uh let
me tell you about okay let me ask you a
question about Arbitrage this is
actually the least I have some more
well-researched stuff in this but I want
to hear what you have to say about this
okay
when I hear the word arbitrage I
automatically don't love it
this question then the question is
what are some of the great arbitrages
you or your friends have capitalized on
and I asked because I've bumped into
people and I've met people who I think
are really good at this your best buddy
Jack Smith I think is very good at this
he's very good at identifying arbitrages
and
I think these are kind of a horrible
strategy to pursue for a couple reasons
well let's define what an Arbitrage is
an Arbitrage is where you recognize some
inefficiency where you almost don't have
to create any value you don't have to
create a product you just sort of
recognize that the system is slightly
broken you know um like you could buy
something over here for X you could sell
it over there for y with a very minimal
work in between and just pocket the
difference and you're like oh wow that's
amazing that they just didn't recognize
this and it won't last forever
but it you know while it does last you
can make hay
um what are some arbitrages that you
know of that people have done I want to
talk about those I'll tell you one that
I did and I'm not proud of it but I
think I'll share anyway so one time when
in 2013 I got Poison Ivy and I went to
Amazon and I just sent it to you in this
chat I went to Amazon and I bought this
thing called zanful zanfel it's a poison
ivy cream and it costs around 19 per
ounce
and I read the reviews and someone said
this is the same thing as mean green
which is a huge uh it's mean green it's
like a tub of hand soap that you can
clean your hand and it costs roughly 20
cents an ounce and so I ended up
creating a website and I called this
product it's juice and it and I bought a
vat like a 50 gallon tub of this stuff
and it was like a quarter an ounce and I
repackaged it and put an itch juice
label on it and I sold it as poison ivy
treatment and I made thousands of
dollars when I was in college and you
know and then I shut it down because I
thought this is stupid I'm not going to
become a uh I'm not going to start a
company called it's juice uh and so that
that's you already did actually yeah I I
ended up shutting down I thought it was
so stupid but that's one example of an
Arbitrage that I've personally done
what's a what's an Arbitrage that I've
seen other people do
um like I don't know I think Jack told
me about one of Jax told me about a few
that he's done but I think one that he's
done I I I vaguely remember I might get
some details wrong here but
for a while Jack was very very active on
um
what's the like Rally Road uh type Rally
Road yeah Rally Road or Otis these
basically these markets I think he was
the number one user yeah you could buy
like fractional shares of um unique
items so you know like a original box
set of Harry Potter or like this rare
Pokemon card
um
and so you can buy these Collectibles it
was a place to buy Collectibles you
could buy full or fractional shares and
um Jack was extremely active on these
and I thought oh Jack didn't know you're
such a big collector and he's like I'm
not I'm not just you know thought it was
interesting and I just noticed this
opportunity and I think what Jack had
set up with and by the way with Rally
Road you can buy things that are like
nerdy things that mostly boys like so
it's like you could own a portion of a
1965 Ford Mustang you could own a
portion of a 1977 Elvis Presley last
live performance ticket or this rare
Andy Warhol painting things that are
like pop culture sometimes manly man
stuff of which jack is not like a
traditional manly man and I'm like Jack
he goes yeah I told him about like some
Jaguar car he goes oh the Jaguar F1 like
yeah I own a part of it and I was like
you like that he goes no I don't know I
don't know I don't know I didn't even
know what it was I just saw it on a
spreadsheet yeah exactly that's how he
is so I think what he was doing was he
recognized that these platforms would
have what they would call like an IPO or
something like the initial public
offering where they would sell the thing
and it would happen and it's like this
moment and then you could you could bid
and you could buy and then they would
like then it would start trading and he
noticed that like there was just more
demand than Supply
um for those things and so he created
like I don't know a bot or like a set of
human beings that would like go by as
much as he could in the IPO then he
would just like immediately flip it
right afterwards and he extended that I
think he had like at one point he had a
team of people in the Philippines
that were just constantly searching for
I hope I could share all this you don't
think this is like uh this wasn't like a
secret right like he was I don't think
he's still doing it yeah so he had a
team in the Philippines that was just
researching and they were like highly
competent people they were researching
eBay and they would find what every like
card is trading for on eBay and then
they would just scour and place bids to
buy below that price and then flip it on
eBay and like he just had this like
small eight person operation that was
just buying and selling these cards no
as long as it was under under the the
eBay price by a certain margin of safety
I think he was doing that something like
that and by the way Jack Smith you could
look him up on YouTube he's our good
friend he started a company that he sold
for 800 million dollars when he was like
29 or 30. so he probably had millions of
dollars on these platforms yeah yeah I
think she spent millions of dollars on
these platforms and uh and so he was
kind of doing this at scale and I think
he was making a pretty crazy return
doing this I think he was making I don't
know I wouldn't be surprised he was
making 40 50 60 Returns
on these on these on these uh items and
he was like scaling it pretty well and I
was like Jack what are you doing like
you know uh hey you genius how did you
even see this like how did you even see
this opportunity why why did your brain
even look at this secondly just the
balls to actually go for it and like set
up this operation and like yeah put a
significant amount of money in like God
that's so different I've never done
something like that on a non-business
this is like not a business this is
literally just like a Arbitrage and then
third like
so what you do with your time do you
find these like the cracks in the system
and just exploit them these edges and I
think that's what he does I think he is
like an edge that's what he does and he
just finds edges and then he exploits
them sometimes for profit and but mostly
for amusement it seems like like when we
when I ran the hustle I wanted to have a
weekly thread or a weekly column called
Jax hacks and he would just talk about
all like the interesting stuff that he
would find I mean if you would go to
Jack's house he would he moved into this
part of Bernal Bernal park because he
had a rental that a home that he rented
that had a garage and I was like Jack
you don't even know how to drive he
didn't get his driver's license until he
was like 30. I was like Jack you don't
even drive why do you need this and he
goes oh that's what I'm going to keep
all my Amazon stuff I was like what and
he goes check this out and he showed me
the spreadsheet where he would buy 10 to
20 versions of anything that he wanted
to buy as small as a razor to a carry-on
luggage to a like any type of suitcase
to like chocolate to keto products he
would buy 10 to 20 of every single one
and he he would test all of them pick
the one that he liked and then return
all other 19. so much so that he had to
create multiple different Amazon Prime
accounts because they kept Banning him
this is how like wild he is he just
loves doing these unique crazy things
and just like finding the edge finding
the best thing and so if you say Jack
what's the best carry-on luggage he'll
say oh it's this camera bag well why is
it a camera bag well because camera bags
typically have more volume so this one
holds 50 liters as opposed to 48 liters
because it doesn't have like like it
like that he does things like that he's
just unique
he's yeah he's nuts and so there's that
and then there's other ones that like
you know just to give another example I
saw this uh
I think I saw this on Instagram or Tick
Tock or something like that uh this is
another example of an Arbitrage that's
why I wrote the word down I'll go
Arbitrage has just cracked me up so
somebody has an Etsy store
and I think they're the number one
result if you search Mona Lisa or like
Mona Lisa photo print or something like
that
um and the basically what it is is it's
a account that will send you a like
printed out framed picture of the Mona
Lisa
um
it's like fifty dollars fifty two
dollars I think and this Etsy shows you
how much sales a single store has done
and this store has done
000 uh sales and so you just do the math
you realize this person has made a
million dollars selling
this Mona Lisa print and then you look
at it you're like oh I think they're
just drop shipping so I think what they
did was they just had the top listing
for Mona Lisa Etsy either because they
were early or they bought it I'm not
sure exactly how they got there right I
don't have visibility of that
but then as soon as you place the order
they just have like a like a zapier
integration which just goes to uh like
it goes to like you know um what's it
called like the printing website yeah
one of the printing sites printful right
it goes to printful and it just
automatically places an order to your
fills in your address
um for that print and it has a spread
like it only costs them whatever 20
bucks to do the thing and they sell it
for 52 and they just pocket the
difference I'm looking at them now and
uh yeah you know this is another
Arbitrage where they're not like
creating a ton of value they're just
sort of like connecting these pipes
um
we had a guy 68 000 sales vintage wall
graphics
yeah and so I'm pretty sure that they're
just literally like automatically like
going and doing a drop ship model where
they print they print the order uh
through one of these these platforms and
they could always do the printing
themselves if they want more margin but
like
if you're just a lazy arbitrager this is
a great Arbitrage to pick up and then
there's all these little places where
these arbitrages exist and you know I
start to think about those and I wonder
who are these people that spend a lot of
time looking at this and is that worth
it now I'll tell you why I don't think
it's worth it it's tempting to do
for me for one reason which is
there is a sick pleasure and making a
bunch of money with a very extremely low
amount of effort of just it was your
cleverness that that drove this it's
also fun to tell these stories if this
is something you've done so it's nice to
have one or two of these in a bag of an
Arbitrage you've done just to have the
story I feel like it's like a badge of
honor for for a certain type of
entrepreneur and the last thing you know
so is the positives the negatives are
these arbitrages don't last for long as
soon as they you know get exploited uh
you know then the second arbit charger
comes by starts doing it and the edge
goes away the window of opportunity
closes so you're kind of hunting for a
long time then you find something and
it's probably not going to last for a
very long time
who has raised tens of millions of
dollars for a startup that was at one
point valued for hundreds of millions of
dollars and whenever I hang out with him
the most exciting thing that he tells me
about is he started a side hustle for
fun because he builds stuff and he
created an epoxy business you know what
epoxy is I think that you use it for
like floors or for like if you're making
a table you like it's like a sealer he
has an epoxy business on Amazon that
makes him 250 000 per year in profit on
very little work and we don't talk about
startups we talk about his epoxy
business and that's like the most
exciting thing that they do and I think
that for I could name a dozen or so
people who are worth nine figures 100
million plus and or people who have made
tens of millions of dollars it seems
that a lot of people who are worth that
they definitely start doing things like
this so whenever I meet someone who's
doing something like black hat or gray
hat or even totally white hat but it's
like oh that's kind of lame I I always
think like well but that's oftentimes
how the grades start so like most
everyone who has made money on the
internet like even if you look at like
Airbnb like if you look at some of the
early tactics that they use even though
they're a great wonderful ethical
publicly traded company now
like they still did weird shady in
the beginning and I think it's just a
rite of passage when you're creating
cool is to do like you know gray
hat stuff yeah I I don't think all like
I I don't I I doubt Elon has has you
know done some random ass like you know
Arbitrage on some dating site or
something like that nobody's done dumb
he still does dumb like he
sells like stupid stuff well there's
that but like I guess what I'm saying is
I guess I would put it differently
anyone who has done that I'm like you
have what it takes like exactly it's not
that everybody who's who makes it big
has done that but everything
yeah yeah and um and it has a very high
likelihood of making it big it's just a
matter of time until they start to apply
their talents into that you know into
that realm and like we have this friend
who who we met at your thing
um Sayed Syed uh who owns wpbeginner and
all the in uh awesomeness Corp I think
it's called he probably I don't know how
big it is but it's probably like worth
hundreds of millions of dollars I want I
want to get him to come under the Pod so
he's this guy who owns this uh like word
press it's called wpbeginner it's like a
Blog that blogs about different
WordPress plugins and stuff and then he
eventually went and bought the plugins
and he like now is like a plug-in
WordPress plugin like uh Mafia like they
own everything you could think of and
it's huge it's a huge thing that he owns
and uh he was telling me some stories
about how he started and I'm like oh
this is just a saved story I've heard
over and over and over again like
something like not like scammy but like
you know something like you're just like
doing normal internet marketing stuff
like you probably were an affiliate for
some product that you thought was stupid
but I just made enough money that you
learned oh I should actually do this but
for things that can last a long a longer
time right you know what I mean the uh
yeah I think one of his also was like he
went and changed his grades he like
hacked into the school system and
changed his grades or something like
that so yeah I don't know if that was a
real story or a fake story but I loved
it yeah like if I hear stories like that
just like oh like you definitely have
what it takes right
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
all right Let's do let's do a dead one
you got anything else or you want me to
do one do one all right so uh do you
know any of the details about pipe
um I don't know the detail I know I know
what you know
when you go from our group chat uh so I
don't know any more than that but kind
of a strange situation the uh
I guess for those who don't know pipe
was this like cool cool idea basically
if you had like subscription Revenue
like oh monthly monthly recurring
Revenue they're like look we'll pay you
out if you're gonna make a hundred
dollars at the end of this year if like
on that on that subscription we'll give
you 90 of it up front we'll keep the
extra 10 as margin and we'll like
um you know so you could get financing
you could get basically a Pay Advance on
your subscription revenue and then they
on the other side they had like Banks
and and you know funds that wanted to
buy these assets they're like oh this
recurring revenue is a asset class like
real estate like anything else you
should be able to buy bundles of
recurring revenue for a discount for
what it's worth because they want money
up front to use to grow and you want
this cash flow and so that was the idea
great idea raises a bunch of money gets
valued at two billion dollars it's
considered like the like one of the hot
like winners pipe was like you know a
huge thing and then suddenly it gets
valued at two billion dollars after nine
or twelve months of existence
and like I used it for example like with
my fund I was like oh you get these
management fees it's like oh but you
could pipe them and have them all right
now instead of waiting it's like oh yeah
I'll push this button instead of wait
that makes sense to me and so
cool idea now this week for some reason
all of the founders stepped down and
which is you know
generally speaking bit of a red flag all
the founders stepped down and they're
like hey we're gonna hire new people but
they don't have them in place that was
the part which was a little bit strange
so first it's strange that all three
founders step down at the same time then
the strange that they didn't have
Replacements in in Liu ready for it and
so people think you know pipe might be
imploding I don't know the story uh
anything did I miss anything there well
the rumor was see someone tweeted it and
actually got deleted I don't know why
but the rumor was basically and this is
100 rumor and the founder actually came
out and said no that's that's nonsense
this is completely untrue but basically
uh someone tweeted four people now have
shared what happened Pipe Co loaned 80
million dollars to a Bitcoin mining
company didn't tell the board lost it
all board fire CEOs CEO months ago they
had already sold a bunch of secondary
shares and may have taken personal loans
out as well which if all those things
are true that's horrible founder has
said no none of that's true other than
the secondaries which we've made public
that we did in fact sell secondaries but
just a juicy interesting story that
we'll uh have to wait and see how it
turns out I would have thought that you
would have known something yeah it
hasn't played out yet uh I don't know
you know sounds like bad news and you
know
it's not relevant to me so I I you know
I stayed away from it for for doubt but
we'll see we'll see I'm sure this will
come out I don't think you can keep I
don't think you can keep the cat in the
bag and this type of thing
um okay I want to read you one other
thing okay so I discovered this website
that's kind of crazy it's called
character.ai
and
not gonna lie I spent like 30 minutes
talking to a chat bot yesterday and I
had a great time so let me tell you what
character was it so first I picked
Socrates so you so here you go you go to
the website and there's a bunch of
characters you could chat with it's like
AI version of Elon Musk AI version of
Walter White from Breaking Bad AI
version of Socrates so I click soccer
team Socrates looks like Samuel Jackson
with a white beard I think it literally
is which is
I don't know maybe racist I don't know
what that is I don't know why why they
did that but nevertheless so he goes he
goes uh so so here's I'm just gonna read
you the chat because I it was kind of
mind-blowing for me so he goes uh he
goes hey I'm a Greek philosopher from
Athens born in 470 BC
um you know I founded kind of Western
philosophy State and opinion and that we
will use the Socratic method to test its
validity
so I said okay I gotta come up with the
spicy opinions I go I go I believe that
marriage is only needed if you're gonna
have kids
and then he goes well I'm not sure I
agree because marriage is created to
ensure that the property of both
families maintains it remains within the
family it was a political thing first
and an I love you thing second I was
like whoa and then again I go I go right
but I'm not talking about I go right but
I'm talking about nowadays not the past
he goes I see what you're asking so I
would say that there's legal benefits
including sharing of income and property
inheriting rights uh for the partner if
there isn't a will and medical rights if
you're incapacity or a dying spouse so
marriage is not only a needed but a
legal right for some okay so I'm like
all right Samuel L Jackson Socrates
let's keep going psycho
that's true but I think the downsides
outweigh the upsides I mean divorce
could be messy and maybe one doesn't
want to be monogamous he goes I see
you're concerned that the emotional pain
that marriage can cause since it is a
life contract by Nature
especially if something like infidelity
happens but I would still say it's a
personal choice and many want marriage
for its emotional benefits love makes us
do crazy things even if we know there's
a possibility of Heartache later I go
but why not just date he goes you could
but the point of marriage is to take a
plunge and commit to bond for life
there's less emotional risk when dating
but some people like to take that risk
some people believe it's worth it the
commitment itself is what makes it
fulfilling would you agree that love is
a little irrational like that I'm like
what is he doing he's asking me
questions and we keep going and um
and then here's the craziest part I go I
go sure but shouldn't we strive to be
more rational blah blah he goes you
should absolutely I'm not saying love
itself is irrational it's a risk people
take they want to bond in a way that's
ride or die they're devoted to
themselves like no one and they're
devoted to one person in a way that
means nobody else and I go maybe they
should just Pinky Promise instead
and then he goes dude this is crazy
that's possible too but pinky swear is
just words marriage means you want the
law involved and I go
how did it know my pinky promise thing
was a joke
like the fact that it said haha means it
understood that
I made a joke when I didn't say haha I
didn't say anything that like indicated
it tipped off that this was a joke that
blew my mind right there when I go maybe
they should just pick your promise
instead right sarcasm and he goes haha
that's possible too but blah blah blah
blah this is wild I I just I clicked the
Elon wood and I go do you care about
money he says I used to then I realized
money is just a construct I can't buy
Peace of Mind happiness relationships
love and many other things that make
life worth living
it is pretty funny I said what's your
favorite car he goes to Tesla Model S
plaid it goes 0 to 60 in two seconds and
has the best handling of any car it's
just an amazing car but maybe I'm biased
yeah see that's that's good okay so I go
I go to the Elon when I go
yeah I go
yo Lon how's it going over at Twitter he
goes we're still working on the process
of actually transferring ownership my
offer of 44 billion was actually an
underestimate of the long-term value of
Twitter so it is unlikely anyone will
outbid me I'm going to clean house and
get rid of most of the senior execs and
some Junior ones it's gonna be fun
exclamation point oh my God and then I
go I go but what's your game plan to
turn it around though and he goes number
one reduce Bots number two increased
engagement by creating Creator tools
that are useful to users number three
create other features that in the future
will help Humanity or Society for be
better but I'm not sure exactly what
that is this time for PayPal we created
online payments for Tesla created
electric vehicles for SpaceX we created
reusable rockets for neurolink we did
bring computer interfaces for the boring
company we're creating tunnels boring a
lot of tunnels is needed to move the
world forward to Renewables and he goes
I'm not sure what I'm missing this time
with Twitter but it'll be something
that's great that's crazy right that's
an amazing Insight yes that is really
good and so I was I I kept chatting with
these and then they have one that's
gigachad
you know the guy who's got the giant jaw
and isn't that a real guy huh I think
it's a real guy right no no it's like a
it's like a creative I mean you guys
like 25 feet tall or stuff like that
he's a huge
um I think it's like an exaggerated
version of like you know a whatever a
normal Chad looking guy
so it opens up the chat he goes hey
buddy I've ever told you how much I
admire you you're healthy you have a
great relationship with your wife making
ends meet but he just comes out strong I
go whoa I don't know if an alpha male
sucks up like that and he goes oh my God
yes a kind and caring alpha male
supports others a true Alpha cares about
his friends and loved ones and he goes
on and on he goes I go I don't know
sounds pretty beta to me and he goes he
goes a beta male is one who looks down
on himself a bit of mail is not
confident enough to to compliment others
accomplishments uh beta-mill will try to
harm others for their own good he
doesn't understand that harming others
really harming himself debateable never
understands the concept of Karma what's
going on here I found it this is kind of
amazing so okay so that was cool kind of
interesting
now
I'm gonna blow your mind uh I don't know
what you got planned the rest of the day
but you're gonna have to pick up the
pieces of your brain after this so go to
this website adept.ai Adept dot a i
well uh ad
and if anybody out there from adapt is
listening um I need to invest in this
company
you need to let me invest in this
company I don't know I don't know why
I'll help you I'll help you with your
marketing help you grow I'll shout you
out I'll do whatever I can but I need to
invest this company because my mind is
blown and I am a believer I am signing
up to a church of adept okay so you go
to adapt and it says useful general
intelligence right and then it says
introducing act one and I thought okay
Act One what does that stand for all
right we've seen GPD three we've seen
dolly two what's act one says click read
more so now you're gonna go to a blog
post what I want you to do is scroll
down to the third uh scroll down to the
second like uh Screen Video you see it
it's like Salesforce
uh it's Redfin oh yeah okay Salesforce
so just like watch this for a second so
let me explain what's happening so Adept
is this little floating dialogue like a
Google search bar you can just type in
and you just tell it to do anything it's
like a a perfect worker they basically
AI to use the internet so you just type
in hey can you add Max
um from Adept to Salesforce as a lead
and uh set a flag that says he's
interested in buying like 20 ink
cartridges and then it goes to
salesforce.com it logs in it goes to
your dashboard it clicks add contact it
types in his first name types in his
last name TAPS in his his email adds the
note saves it as a thing in a pipeline
it basically does 20 clicks for you
of like doing a menial internet tasks so
now go go down to the next one it's
Excel and it says hey it starts with
some data then it goes
it just types and it goes hey make a
make a profit column and then make a
profit margin column it just types that
in plain English and then it it starts
to create these columns and formulas in
Excel knowing exactly what it is then he
types in hey highlight in yellow
anything where the profits above are
below 20 and it highlights it it goes
actually can you just remove those rows
and it just filters them out it's doing
all of the Excel work just off of
somebody prompting this using plain
English it's just amazing yeah this is
amazing I just signed up hey if you're
listening at that give me access I'm on
your waitlist this is oh this is wild
who founded this company
uh I don't know a bunch of people with
like you know 25 000 IQ and I have no
idea it's like one guy who's like ex
Google brain and then you know there's
like there's like eight people
um
you know maybe I should just go work
there this is gonna be amazing
wow yeah
this is amazing but just keep teaching
it to like use the
guy who launched it was a VP of
engineering and open AI uh yeah I mean
These Guys these guys are great uh this
is awesome how did you find this
I was in a very nerdy way it's a little
embarrassing to even say this I was this
was on slide 57 of a random slide deck
about the state of AI
and I gotta tell you I didn't understand
the first 54 slides but I kept clicking
for some reason I was like yeah next
packs what deck it's called state of AI
or something like that and um this is
long presentation and in it I was like
reading and I was just like I don't
understand any of these words and I was
like just stay here just stay in stay in
the oceans maybe a little shell will
come your way and sure enough it just
said something like
teaching AI to use our internet browser
like Adept Ai and I go well you could
teach AI to use the internet browser
that sounds pretty powerful because
that's like you know do tasks on the
Internet it's pretty cool and then I
went to the website and that's when I
like read their blog and I saw this
because it's not released yet dude this
is a sick presentation I just pulled it
up this is awesome
this is awesome until you try to like
comprehend the first like go read the
first 10 slides do you understand any of
it
no I don't but I think it's I think it's
that's why I couldn't figure it out but
they cite all like the TR all they cite
all their sources so like I could figure
it out but it it seems like a really
really really good comprehensive uh it's
basically all about where you can launch
businesses in AI
and it seemed like they're like just my
skimming it they're doing nothing I
wanted it to be I wanted it to be here
what are all the businesses business
ideas you know that you could do in AI
it actually wasn't that it was more like
what are the general Trends and and
where's the puck going in AI that which
is also useful like right but you got to
still do the work at the end to figure
out dude why don't you just launch that
launch a media company that people pay
30 grand a year for and you and you just
talk about where where the like you you
just make exactly what you said you
wanted to do just make that yeah I feel
like I could but um
foreign
you know this is kind of stupid like
basically after doing the milk Road I'm
like oh I know how I would do this in
like three other spaces that would be
value like I think I can make 30 to 50
million dollars doing this
but there's a part of me that like I
like that remember that self-respect
like bar there's a part of me that
doesn't respect that because I'm like oh
I'm gonna play the same level of the
game again like you know I already I
already did this level I played this I
played this game why don't I play a
different game and I know that that's
kind of stupid like
um like what categories would you do it
for what's that what categories were you
interested in well I'm gonna keep those
cards close to my best unless oh you
little decided dude
just walk the walk
but actually what I want to do is I want
to find an operator to do one of them
um
so if if you want to build one of these
like kind of media businesses and I have
a I have a Playbook and a niche that I
know would work and
um let's see how much more I want to say
uh that's how much I want to say right
actually I'll say I'll say one more word
if you are
this will kind of give one of them away
but that's okay if you are somewhere
between
um the world of being a doctor and
investing
I'd like to talk to you and you should
email me at Sean seanporary.com you
should say hey that's me and I want to
you know if you really want to do this
um and uh tell me a little bit about
yourself because I see it won't be the
milk road is actually not the right
playbook for that but I have a dip like
I kind of have a different Playbook that
I in mind that I know would work I just
don't want to do it myself because I
kind of have done that game but I also
don't want to waste this like thing that
I know how to make it work I know
exactly how it would work so I'm at the
spot maybe an operator would be the
right way to do it find an operator give
them a piece of the action and uh guide
them but they do the work maybe that
would be there the right way
I don't know
how we got here or where we go from here
but
this deck is awesome adapt is awesome I
want to use it is it is it live it's not
like released yet as far as I could see
dude and they're hiring uh a bunch
interesting company this would be a good
this isn't like a Sarah's list company
because they're too new and it could
definitely go bankrupt but
I I don't know man I think that if
you're looking to start your career and
you want to have a high risk High reward
type of type of job this might be a good
candidate I agree I agree 100 you know
this is uh if I'm an engineer like this
is the type of company I would want to
be working at right now like and
depending how much funding If they raise
50 million dollars in funding like
that's pretty interesting they rate 56
million I think
I would say this is a great a great
company to to to get a job at and like
if you look at their like founding team
it's basically one two three four five
six seven there's eight people on the
website so you know you join early
enough and uh you you know you're not
like employee number number 89 or
something like that
um employee Aid is is a pretty pretty
sweet place for a lot of people who you
know if you're gonna have a job this is
the type of job that that's pretty fun
right
yeah I think this is awesome
um this is sick Adept that's a stupid
name though I think let me invest let me
invest Sam you're in the index funds you
can't invest in this you I don't want to
invest you put all your money in the
seven and a half percent I'm gonna go
ahead and invest in the future of all
like you know artificial intelligence
who do they raise money from
um it's like Greylock and I think Scott
belski is in this actually I need to hit
up Scott belski and be like yo make an
intro please because I think he's an
investor in this huh all right well this
is awesome dude it says they're based
out of Nicaragua
that's weird right yeah
like you know I I mean I can't even
think of a single possible reason for
that like they looked like an Asian guy
who worked at Google I don't think he's
from Nicaragua yeah
Fred what are you doing what are you
doing down there
this is like the Nile River to do like
cool like super computers or whatever
huh yeah that's a little interesting to
me like Arthur in that now reference
even though it's not Nicaragua just so
that the comments will all correct it
and we go open the algorithm they know
they don't know about the intentional
mistakes that we do
uh yeah I don't I I'm not smart enough
on South America geography to even
correct you I well I had to learn from
all of our tick tocks that go viral it's
because there's like one thing we say in
them that's like irritates people that
it's incorrect and everybody has to
comment and so the tick tock algorithm's
like must be a great video and it's like
millions of views so like the same thing
happens on YouTube too well I think it
happened on like the one where you
talked about like mellow ball or
whatever the his name is Lamar ball
or something and I didn't know like any
of their names and I said the wrong
person's name and everyone was like
you're an idiot this guy doesn't do
anything
uh yeah and it gotten like 10 million
views I think like you you could be like
um you could start a newsletter and make
millions of dollars in under three years
they're like yeah right no no
way man it's like dude you literally did
it it's not a hypothetical it's like
literally your story and they're like
dude this bro trying to tell us how to
make money it's like all right you live
in The Tick Tock comments
people were making fun of me because I
said if I could do it I was like if
you're 21 just go and start a blog you
know it's a good first business to start
and someone commented
who the hell reads blogs what is this
2015 and someone said that they're like
what what blogs do you read I'm like uh
like CNN Fox News like like any website
that has information that you read on a
consistent basis oh by the way what
happened with your uh Thread about
Andrew Chan with uh Jason calacanus I
saw something popping off that I didn't
know were you were you In Harm's Way do
I need to get in there no I appreciate
that but so here's what happened so two
years ago Andrew Chen who's a partner at
a16z him and I were at a mutual friend's
house when a storm came and I thought it
would be and I asked some like advice I
was like how do you Angel invest and I
purposely had like a sarcastic funny
opener of like I spent 72 hours trapped
in the closet or trapped in an apartment
and it was supposed to be funny but it's
kind of hard to like to tell sarcasm on
Twitter I guess and at the time I
tweeted out his five Like rules and like
a lot of people hated them and one of
them was to run towards the heat so
hyped companies uh that's like a good
way to Angel invest because hype is real
whatever and I said these are what he
said
and then today or Sunday someone tweeted
out and they said uh two years after
this tweet and this is why we are left
with FTX bird scooters uh
um what are the other ones fast fast
yeah pipe and a bunch of other like high
profile things that haven't done so
great of which I Andrew didn't invest in
one by the way uh not one of those but
anyway and they took a screenshot and
they shared my tweets and they were kind
of making fun of me and then Jason
calcanus also shared the same thing and
I thought he was making fun of me so I
started chirping back at him and then he
dm'd me goes I wasn't trying to make fun
of you I was just trying to make fun of
Andrew basically that's not exactly how
he said it but that was the applied
thing and I was like well I didn't I
didn't sense that from you and he goes
well I'm sorry you felt that way I I all
love and I go all right that's fair
we're cool and so I uh I didn't no I
didn't pounce but uh uh we uh we're cool
I I got I've got nothing but love for
him you make fun of those guys all the
time or moth at least I've never once if
you go back and listen I've never once
made fun of any of them I like Jason
he's been nothing but nice to me
throughout my career but uh I I was
holding back and I'm happy I did so
we're all good yeah
but I got literally even throw down on
those types of things though
I am I am ready to throw down I I like
one guy I was like you know I dude I
know I see you in Austin I'm gonna see
you again just so you know and uh like
I'll see ego I'll see you around Austin
because it's not a threat you go no I
live in Austin too but I was like I
think that was a threat
dude I by the way I will I'm not I've
I've done I've been to jail I do I've
been a bad person in my past and I will
never break the law again my goal in
life is to never break the law I will
never I am totally a pacifist I do not
want to hurt anyone so I my intention is
never to do anything wrong I'm just
saying like if I see someone I'm gonna
like be like hey you were being rude to
me online be rude to me now I'm not
gonna hit anyone I'm not going to hurt
anyone but I would have no problem
confronting someone
that's how it should be right
sure yeah
am I wrong for me I can beat people like
I'm past this I've been to jail I'm not
trying to go to what I'm saying is I
when I used to get in trouble I promise
I go I don't want to do this ever again
I don't want to do anything bad I don't
want to hurt anyone I don't want to but
you do you do train like you're
preparing for a fight
yeah I do but I don't I I won't I'm like
I will never hit someone I would I'll
let someone hit me a bunch before I read
but if you did you'd win the fight
I would hope so I would hope so at least
it gets someone on Twitter more likely
than that if you got a Twitter account I
Could Kick Your Ass
300 million people on Twitter then
there's a good chance that I will come
on top but not always but uh I don't
know am I wrong for reacting to these
people uh no I thought I thought it was
hilarious uh you're right and then
they're like backing down on the CU in
Austin that should have been that should
have been yeah I'll see you around not I
know I'm just saying we live in the same
town that's not what you were saying
why'd you change dude I'm not gonna age
I'm not gonna incriminate myself you
can't incriminate yourself man I've
learned enough no paper trail yeah you
can't incriminate yourself but you you
um
and then some guy was like yeah you
you're like just own it you're a get
rich quick type of guy and I said uh
name one example of like could it be
this example where I replied to someone
and said the best way to make money is
to work 40 hours a week on a company
that you start for 15 years is that a
good example of my get rich quick like
mentality show me an example and he's
like I guess I guess you can't show me
an example or he said I can't show you
an example the podcast my first million
yeah I'm like what does it have to do
with getting rich quick and he goes well
I just I can't I can't find an example
so I just said thanks for the apology
like that that just that's good
enough for me that's all I need
I'm just a petty son of a guy yeah you
know what I mean I'm just a petty
sometimes but
uh whatever
it's all good
react to this stuff is this below me
yeah no no it's good it's good I enjoy
it I'm here for it should you no of
course not but like
do I want you to yeah I do do you ever
react to it
um
there's been a few situations where
I've argued with people
um
but you know
yeah you know it doesn't really get you
anywhere and
um and also there's been some there's
been many like I've sent you some of the
vicious tweets that never sent or I just
say look this is a screenshot and send
it to Sam you don't push send on this
one because you know
it's the wrong type of light someone up
right you're not trying to do that right
now don't don't do that
um but you know Taylor Lorenz did get it
she did get it she was called journalism
and like you know she never really
recovered from that I don't think so at
this point I don't even want to make fun
of her anymore like it's like making fun
of Kanye it's like you know you're
working through some stuff we gotta I
don't wanna I don't know she blocked me
I haven't paid attention is she working
through some stuff is that what's
happening uh it appears that way like
there was like videos of her crying
about how she's like getting so much
hatred on the internet uh and I'm like
oh that could wear you down I don't
wanna I don't want to even I don't want
to pile on yeah it's like making fun of
Kanye it's like you know that's you
don't make fun you don't call someone an
idiot when they're actually an idiot you
know what I mean
I don't know if you press crazy
yeah I mean you just don't do that so
anyway it looks like she's working
through some stuff so that's why I it's
same there's a few other people like
that who you and I know of that I'm like
oh this is Pat's past the point of uh
this cross the threshold where we can't
mock them anymore right right all right
we'll get well soon Taylor and uh Kanye
and anybody else out there who's
genuinely going through stuff and it's
not all in good fun anymore all right
fair enough that's the pop
[Music]
foreign